do
welcome to session 63 of the world of
speculative fiction
series this time we're going to be
looking at these three novels by j.g
ballard from the 1970s crash concrete
island
and high rise now if you're already
familiar with the worlds of speculative
fiction series because you've you know
watched some of these or even come to
some of the sessions welcome back if
you're not familiar with it what is this
series about so it is about worlds
narrative worlds that are created by
speculative fiction authors speculative
fiction covers everything from fantasy
sci-fi and horror sort of the old
standbys to alternate history to
dystopian novels and all sorts of other
interesting things as well
and in this series which started back in
2016 originally meeting at the
brookfield public library as an
in-person session and then in covid
moving entirely online what we do is we
look at authors in speculative fiction
who have some sort of narrative world
spanning stories or in this case
novels that we can sink our teeth into
and we can explore their world building
that goes on
uh talk about some of the key
philosophical themes we usually spend
some time for authors we haven't done in
the past on their biography looking
sometimes at their own takes on their
own work their influences so there's a
lot of things that we cover
in this now i had been asked for years
and years because every year towards the
end of any particular calendar year i
start soliciting feedback on who should
we do next and i usually have some
people picked out and then i let my
fans and followers participate in a
online activity where they pick out some
people have been asking for jg ballard
for a long time and the only jg ballard
book that i had read previously was this
one crash and i read it back in the
1990s so a long long time ago obviously
i'd seen the movie which you know kind
of parallels the book kind of doesn't
and i hadn't read anything else by him
and people kept asking for him and kept
asking for him and so i went online and
looked what did this guy actually
write and it turned out that
there were three world
books early on in his career
and we'll get to those actually next
year we're going to look at those three
novels of dystopian worlds but i thought
for this time because it was time to
include ballard
i should
look at these books from the 1970s these
followed each other
very quickly
crash is 1973 concrete island is 1974
and then high rise is 1975 and ballard
himself
saw a kind of continuity between these
these books so i think that they
make an excellent
world to explore and i will say that i
am very happy that people did keep
pushing for ballard uh i'm a little bit
of a
stick in the mud you know i like to read
the authors that i know i like and spend
my time on them and when i hear people
talking about oh how great this other
author is particularly when you've read
them in the past and you weren't that
impressed
um you know i often don't want to get to
them and i'm so happy that i did because
these books are actually
quite good i i will say i i don't like
crash as much as i do like concrete
island and high rise
i also read a number of ballard's short
stories and some of his essays and i'm
i'm going to keep reading more and more
because i am
really enjoying the
reads so what we're going to do in this
session we'll
we'll start out by talking a little bit
about the each of these works in part
because sometimes we don't get to that
until much later
and then we'll talk a little bit about
his
life history his biography
and then i've got a number of excerpts
from interviews with ballard where he is
talking about his own process
and his ideas and what he's trying to do
in these works what he's trying to
capture so we'll look at that stuff and
then we'll talk specifically
about
philosophical themes that we can
identify and
unpack
within these three works and there's
quite a few of them so we probably won't
get to
everything
as usual with these sessions this runs
on youtube as a video premiere where we
have some live chat some interactivity
followed up by a zoom video conferencing
session if you missed that
and you're watching this later that's
all right we'll come back someday to
ballard and look at some of his other
novels and down the line i might put
together
something for fans of the worlds of
speculative fiction where we can do a
bit more
regular interaction but for now
sit back and uh check out what we've got
coming up we'll talk about each of these
books a little bit we'll go into the
biography we'll look at the
interviews and what ballard himself has
to say about his own process and his own
ideas and then we'll get into some
really key philosophical themes involved
in the world building in these three
excellent novels
since we haven't covered jg ballard in
the worlds of speculative fiction series
previously we should do some
biographical background on him which is
important for seeing where these three
novels fit in and how he got to the
place where
he was
writing in the ways that he was and
taking up the themes that he was and
ballard had
quite an interesting and long
life so he's born in 1930 to
james and edna ballard christened james
graham ballard and he's born in the
shanghai international
settlement and this was a place in
shanghai in china
where originally it was supposed to be
british american and french people all
living there france pulled out of the
agreement and it was a place uh under
foreign control which is a very common
thing in parts of china at that time and
going back a ways where british and
american people
lived a quote american style of life so
it was kind of an oasis you could say
apart from the rest of the city and
indeed the rest of china he gets sent to
cathedral school the anglican holy
trinity church in shanghai
for his schooling at first and then when
he's seven years old um the
sino-japanese war starts up again and
the ballards are forced to evacuate
their home in the suburbs and rent a
house in central shanghai in order to
avoid the artillery and the fighting
that's going on between chinese and
japanese forces in that year as well his
sister margaret is born to the ballards
and then in 1941
which you know americans think mostly
about pearl harbor but earlier in the
year
the japanese are attacking hong kong
and they occupy the international
settlement in shanghai
so
already there you know war is becoming a
major part of of his life in 1943
the ballards are interned along with all
the other allied civilians and they're
sent to the longhua civilian assembly
center
and they live in a small area
in a block that's a residence for 40
families
ballard himself is still attending
school in the camp and it's the camp
inmates who organize and teach the
students there so there's quite a bit of
chaos and as he will tell us you know
later on violence
in his life and then you know eventually
the war comes to an end they are
liberated in 1945
his mother returns to britain with
ballard and his sister and they live in
the outskirts of plymouth you know down
in the
southwest of of england and he goes to
the
lay school in cambridge and
wins an
essay prize
eventually his mother and sister are
going to go back to shanghai and join uh
rejoin his father who's still there
working and ballard will stay with his
grandparents when he's not boarding
at school so he's living already a
fairly
independent life one again marked by
considerable
chaos and things like that in 1949 he
goes to cambridge and he
is planning on studying medicine
wants to become a psychiatrist
and
in 1951 in the course of his studies he
writes a short story called the violent
noon and it gets published in the
newspaper magazine varsity and it wins a
competition and so ballard decides at
that time to switch not just his majors
but his intended profession
in life he goes to study english at
queen mary at the university of london
in 1952 he leaves without completing his
degree
and begins working as a copywriter for
an advertising agency he also starts
selling encyclopedias so he's moving
from a medical frame to a
you could say
atmosphere an environment that is
centered around
words and knowledge and all of those
sorts of things in 1954 he joins the
royal air force and he undergoes pilot
training in canada
and there he says
that a lot of his time
where he was is spending in moose draw
canada he begins reading american
science fiction magazines and this helps
him you know sort of discover the field
and then he he also writes his first
science fiction story passport to
eternity
in 1955 he leaves the royal air force
returns to england
works as a science editor again working
within the the realm of words and then
he marries
helen mary matthews who is a secretary
at the daily express and they settle in
chiswick
in
1956 his their first son
jim is born and he publishes two short
stories
um escarpment uh and prima belladonna in
new worlds and science fantasy so he's
starting to make a profession as a
writer the next year 1957 his daughter
faye is born he goes to
one of the first uh for him science
fiction conventions uh in london and he
finds it to be just terrible he doesn't
like the experience at all he leaves
demoralized and disillusioned uh he
doesn't like that that sort of thing now
it's not that ballard was a recluse or
anything like that as we see you know
him putting on exhibitions and things
like that
but he didn't like
the way science fiction was being done
at the time he's going to become this is
a bit of a side note he's going to
become part of what gets called the new
wave of science fiction and and
associate himself with you know uh
people that are that are involved in
that where
the focus is less on gadgets and
space opera and much more on exploring
the interior world of human beings and
incorporating
matters from other disciplines
coming back to his story in 1958 ballard
begins working as an assistant editor in
a scientific journal chemistry and
industry
um in 1959 his third child his daughter
baya is born and they moved to a house
in charlton road in shepparton
and then in 1960 they move uh to to
surrey in 1961
he writes his first novel and now the
story of this is kind of funny and a bit
cynical as well
so he knows that in order to get himself
established he has to have a novel
out there
and he
he writes this over a two-week holiday
why does he do it to get a you know a
foot in the door you could say as a
professional writer it's one thing to
write short stories it's another to
write novels and it's going to make him
some decent money
it's called the wind from nowhere and
ballard himself didn't really like it
that much as a novel compared to the
things that he writes afterwards but you
know everybody's got to do what they got
to do i suppose then in 1962 he resigns
from his job at chemistry and industry
and he be he becomes a full-time writer
he is changing he's been working with
words now he's going to do that
on his own terms full time and the first
of the three world books get published
the drowned
world and he also publishes the voices
of time and other stories gathering
together some of his short stories in
1964 just two years later the burning
world is published and then a
catastrophe
happens
over a holiday in spain
his wife mary dies rather suddenly of
pneumonia and there's a lot of you know
discussion what what's going to happen
are you going to like take the kids
yourself are you going to
try to you know
farm them out to relatives or something
like that and ballard decides that he is
going to
you know do his writing work and he's
going to raise these kids himself and
these these children are pretty young
admittedly ballard begins you know
drinking more and more and is not the
best uh the most attentive of parents um
but that's that's what he's doing in
1965 you know and you could also say as
ballard recognizes
his life takes a kind of
darker turn
with the death of his wife it's not as
if he hasn't seen a lot of darkness and
violence and you know
atrocities prior to that but this really
hits home with him
and he begins working on stories that
are going to be part of a book called
the atrocity
exhibition so that starts in 1965.
uh he also meets martin bax and becomes
the pros editor of ambit magazine you
know it's always good to have extra gigs
on the side
1966 the crystal world
is published
um and so that that brings those worlds
to kind of a close
a few years later his friend and fellow
author michael morcock introduces him to
the woman who's going to become his
partner for effectively the rest of his
life claire walsh
who
you know he's going to stay with uh over
over time and then in 1969 the atrocity
exhibition is published now this is a
different kind of work i mean this is
definitely there to throw things in
people's faces
and it's marking a different turn
for ballard's own uh work and
development in 1970 following up on that
he stages an exhibition at the new arts
laboratory in london entitled crashed
cars which is exactly that crashed cars
and he's going to talk as we're going to
see in just a bit about what the effects
of that were
then in 1973 we see the publication of
crash
and very shortly afterwards we
1974 we have concrete island
1975 high rise and so those are the main
things i mean he's doing a lot of short
story writing on the way as well but
we're not going to talk about all the
many many short stories that he wrote in
1979 he brings out the unlimited dream
company
in 1981 hello america is published and
in that year the philosopher jean
baudrillard hails crash as the first
great novel of the universe of
simulation something that we'll talk
about when we get to the
philosophical themes
in 1984
he publishes a different kind of work
empire of the sun which is a
you know
semi-autobiographical very
autobiographical
novel and he wins a number of prizes the
guardian fiction and james type black
memorial prizes
for empire the sun he's also shortlisted
for the booker prize for fiction and
empire the sun will
end up being filmed by steven spielberg
in 1987 the same year that he brings out
the day of creation in 1988 so you can
see how productive he is running wild is
published and then in 1991 a follow-up
memoir the kindness of women winds up
being published as well so he's
proceeding through the decades you could
say right
in 1994 we have rushing to paradise 1996
cocaine knights
in 1997 he'll be awarded an honorary
doctorate by de montfort university
which is always kind of a nice
thing for people especially if they
weren't able to finish their education
in 2000 he publishes super con and the
atrocity exhibition is filmed by
jonathan weiss
in 2001 he wins uh for super con the
commonwealth writers prize for europe
and south asia region and then uh we
should going back of course
you know we should mention that crash
itself in 1996
was turned into a
a film as controversial as the book is
controversial
and
possibly as perverse as the book is
perverse uh big name uh actors in it of
course you know james spader
uh elias cortez and the whole cat holly
hunter a whole cast of other
characters as well
in 2003 millennium people is published
and in that year he's offered a uh cbe
but refuses it calling it a ruritanian
charade that helps prop up our top heavy
monarchy so he's rejecting the
institution of that
in 2006 kingdom come is published and
that year he is diagnosed with prostate
cancer which is unfortunately
going to be terminal because it
metastasizes
to his spine and ribs a little bit of a
side note you know nowadays having
prostate cancer if they catch it early
enough is not the death sentence that it
it often was
back in the day
and um you know
i have actually had relatives who who
died of it you know much much earlier
and you know things have changed quite a
bit so he winds up getting cancer
um 2008 he wins a golden pen award
the miracle of life is published and he
spends the last year of his life at
claire walsh's home as he is succumbing
to
his cancer and then finally in
2009 he's going to die at claire walsh's
home he will be given a posthumous
honorary doctorate by royal holloway
university
of london as well in that year and
there's there's some things that get
published later on but this gives you
kind of the scope of james graham
ballard's
life you know born in 1930 dies in 2009
he you know
writes about the new millennium that's
coming and then gets to see it actually
happening a very interesting
feature for a science fiction author to
get to see the creep into the
newer eras
plural
of
a new century a new millennium
before we look at some of the things
that ballard has to say about his own
work and process and ideas that he has
in mind i think it would be worth
spending a little bit of time talking
about
all three in each of these three books
that follow each other in such a quick
succession and which are ostensibly
connected to each other in a shared
narrative universe of what is often
called a modern or postmodern dystopia
philosophical theme that we'll be
exploring a little bit later on
during this but we should talk about
what these are just in case anybody
hasn't read them or needs a little bit
of refresher so we begin with crash
and if you've read crash you know that
it is a book that is not only filled up
with automobile
matters including car crashes but also
with a lot of sex which is very much
detached from emotionality and is
happening mostly in cars
it's you know
ballard is going to
uh discuss his relation which he doesn't
really have to the marquis de sade but
it is a somewhat reminiscent of decades
novels where you're basically putting
together human beings and their sexual
organs in whatever combinations you
possibly
can and you know it's you can't go a
chapter without running into that but
the book is not just about having sex in
cars that are getting crashed
it's about obsession it's about
eccentricity it's about figuring out how
to deal with trauma
with damage and the relationships that
the characters
have with each other the the main
character's name the one who is telling
the story is named ballard and he is um
you know involved with his wife
katherine
and this guy vaughn who will be another
main character and then a whole bunch of
other people as well he gets into a car
crash in which
he he ends up well
it ends up killing a
doctor's husband
who then he gets involved with and
actually has an affair with as well
so
that's what the book crash is about and
it's going to begin
with uh this character
vaughn and it's going to kind of end
with him but it's really about
ballard and catherine and their
relationship mediated through
so many other people and through
the
rather graphic sex and sexuality
that is being uh displayed in the novel
so that's that's crash what about um
concrete island
this also involves cars
and it takes place in an island now what
it what is a concrete island well it's
in between all of these different
highways an island is the area of waste
space between these highways bounded by
them
and uh the the main character is you
know driving along it actually begins
the first thing is through the crash
barrier soon after the three o'clock on
the afternoon of april 22nd 1973 a 35
year old architect named robert maitland
was driving down the high speed exit
lane of the westway interchange in
central london several hundred yards
from the junction with the newly built
spur the m4 motorway when the jaguar had
already passed the 70 mile per hour
speed limit a blowout collapsed the
front side tire
the exploding air reflected from the
concrete parapet seemed to detonate
inside robert maitland's skull and what
ends up happening is his car goes off
the road
crashes
uh breaks his his leg among other things
and now he's stuck in the island and
he's hoping that you know an ambulance
will come and a tow truck will pull his
car out of there
but he's lost and this is talked about
as like a modern-day robin caruso right
um
and it is kind of like that there it
turns out as we find out about um you
know
uh
good ways into it about halfway through
it that there's other people
on the island and they're kind of
screwed up just like maitland turns out
to be screwed up himself
and you know by the very end of the work
we're we're not really sure whether he's
ever going to get off of the island as a
matter of fact i'll read you
the very
end of it
a police car moved along the motorway
the co-driver watching the deep grass
securing his pavilion maitland waited
for it to pass when it had gone he stood
up and gazed confidently across the
island he felt lightheaded from hunger
but calm and in control of himself he
would collect food from the perimeter
fence and perhaps as a gesture in the
direction of the old [ __ ] leave a token
portion beside his grave in a few hours
it would be dusk
maitland thought of catherine and his
son
he would be seeing them soon when he had
eaten it would be time to rest and to
plan his escape from the island
but we don't really know because oh you
know just a
the paragraph before already he felt no
real need to leave the island and this
alone confirmed he'd establish his
dominion over it so what we've got here
is is a very interesting
kind of adventure story a self-discovery
story and then we have high-rise what is
happening in this well it is in a
high-rise apartment in which things are
going to be breaking down
and it begins here as well
later as he sat on his balcony eating
the dog doctor dr robert lang reflected
on the unusual events that had taken
place within this huge apartment
building during the previous three
months now that everything had returned
to normal he was surprised there'd been
no obvious beginning no point beyond
which their lives had moved into a
clearly more sinister dimension with its
40 floors and thousand apartments its
supermarket and swimming pools bank and
junior school
all in effect abandoned in the sky
the high-rise offered more than enough
opportunities for violence and
confrontation
and
what what is he referencing there well
people move into this high-rise
apartment
and over time
things begin to break down and it's not
just the building amenities
and infrastructure that's breaking down
it's the
social relations within the building
itself you know the higher floors are
more elite the lower floors are for
people who don't matter quite as much
and as you go up you know the class
structure is reflected in that but it's
a dynamic class structure
which allows for you know risers and
fallers
and
not only do does the social structure
break down human beings
begin to break down themselves some of
them just becoming completely
traumatized and passive some of them
becoming hyper aggressive banding
together in gangs to either protect
their own areas against the invaders or
to go out doing raids on others and what
we see is a whole series of provocations
and responses ultimately
leading to most of the people within the
building either leaving or dying
and
turning the building
into a massive
wreck so we have these three very
interesting
studies you could say
in late
modern
life all set more or less you know
within the the sphere of london
and all set in the 1970s
but
speaking to us very much
today i would say in the present because
it's interesting you think about how the
about the fact that we're living in the
future
of those times as somebody who was born
in 1970 and remembers all the you know
dystopian and sci-fi things from the 70s
and 80s and even
90s it's striking to be in a time in the
2020s where a lot has changed you know
for example we're
communicating with each other uh
here in my apartment streaming onto the
internet right
and yet we're driving around in cars and
accidents are still happening and
buildings are being planned for people
that don't really suit them and the the
sort of uh survivor stories that we find
in concrete island still take place
today as well so not that much has
actually
changed radically
since then it's just become
different or more complex or more
reflected
so
that gives you at least a sense of what
we're moving into as we talk about the
philosophical themes involved in these
novels and folded into these novels and
ballard's own views on his own writing
over the course of his life and career
balor did countless interviews many of
which are available
online and i have excerpted the portions
of them that i thought were most
interesting or revealing or helpful in
understanding him as an author and the
ones that pertain in particular
to these three books and situate them
within the you could call it larger
projects
and
obsessions of his writerly
work so a great place to start is with
the high times interview where he's
asked how do you think your books have
changed ballard responds my earliest
three or four novels which are more
explicitly science fiction are all
heavily influenced by the surrealists
max ernst ali and also the symbolist
painters like gustav moreau once you get
to the atrocity exposition
exhibition crash high-rise and so on
there's sort of technological books set
in the present day you've got all the
imagery that the titles themselves are
about you name it everything from car
crashes
to the kennedy assassinations to
high rises to motorways right any
another great interview is with simon
sellers and sellers brings up the
earlier books you know these uh world
books you could call them the
environmental disaster theme of your
earlier work doesn't get name checked as
much as the urban disaster themes in
your later work like these
why is that
and ballard responds
i suppose it's because the kind of urban
disaster imagery i wrote about in
atrocity
exhibition and crash and high high-rise
is closer to people's lives not many
people have visited a jungle recently or
a desert people are very concerned about
ecological damage to the planet but it
tends to be something you see on
television whereas
decaying inner city ghetto blocks
high-rise blocks and car crashes are
part of everyday life if you live in a
big city in the west or in the east
for
that matter
in the literary review interview
there's a bit of a
shift here
you've said several times that in the
that the disasters your characters face
lead them to a certain kind of psychic
fulfillment maitland in concrete island
ballard and crash laying in high-rise
may all be said to have staged the
catastrophes themselves to a certain
extent but what about sanders in the
crystal world ransom in the draught and
karen's in the drowned world to what
extent would you consider reading of
these works valid which claim that the
natural disasters depicted are mere
externalizations of the character's
subconscious drives and desires and
ballard says
i think that's very fair
it's quite true that in crash concrete
island and high rise the characters
almost consciously create the disaster
that's not true in the case of the other
three books you mentioned because of
course it's not possible for an
individual to arrange for the ice caps
to melt in london to be flooded or for a
drought to turn a whole hemisphere into
a desert
but what would have happened to these
characters had these global disasters
not taken place it's an interesting
question he says
and then following up
in the inner landscape interview
ballard is asked how would you view the
role of the writer in the next century
ballard says this is something that
bothers me
all the time because the writer's whole
relationship to a subject matter has
changed
and totally transformed a hundred years
ago one had the impression that people
had made a clear distinction between the
outer world of work
and of agriculture commerce and social
relationships which was real
and the inner world of their own minds
daydreams and hopes
fiction on the one hand reality on the
other this reality which surrounded
individuals the writer's role of
inventing a fiction that encapsulated
various experiences going on in the real
world and dramatizing them in fictional
form it worked
now
the whole situation has been reversed
the exterior landscapes of the 70s are
almost entirely fictional ones created
by advertising mass merchandising
politics conducted as advertising it's
very difficult for the writer
given that external reality
is a fiction
the writer's role is almost superfluous
he does not need to invent the fiction
because it is already there
so now he has a much more analytic role
you can see this coming in new writers
who do cut ups with their material i can
visualize the writer and i've already
started doing this reading scientific
journals and taking his fiction
ready made from them because science is
now the greatest producer of fiction and
there are thousands of scientific
journals produced particularly the soft
sciences the psychological sciences
these social sciences it is absolutely
extraordinary the material that they are
churning out look at the psychological
abstracts for example so what is ballard
saying here this is something that we're
going to get to
in the philosophical themes there's been
a fundamental transformation of our
culture
in late capitalism or late modernity
whatever you want to call it
post-modernity if you like
and the
breakdown between the inner world which
was you know imaginary fictional and the
external world which was real
that boundary has shifted and dissolved
in many respects although not
disappeared
entirely so
very interesting point being made there
in simon seller's interview returning
back to that one
he says to ballard according to collins
ballardian or ballardian is defined as
resembling or suggestive of the
conditions described in jg ballard's
novels and stories especially
dystopian modernity
but surely your writing is far too
playful to be branded dystopian i find
your characters and situations affirming
for all the darkness they willingly
surround themselves with a very
provocative
statement there and ballard responds
saying
i'm glad you said that i think that my
work is superficially dystopian
in some respects
but i'm trying to as you say affirm a
more positive worldview isn't that an
interesting thing for him to
respond with he says i lived through
more than two-thirds of the last century
which was one of the grimmest epochs in
human history a time of unparalleled
human violence and cruelty most of my
writing was about the 20th century and
anyone writing about the 20th century
writes in a dystopian mode without
making any effort at all it just comes
with a box of paint brushes
you know to be a human being is quite a
role to play
each of us wakes up in the morning and
we inhabit a very dangerous creature
capable of brilliance in many ways but
also capable of huge self-destructive
episodes and we live with this dangerous
creature every minute we're awake
something like the atrocity exhibition
sums up my fiction the attempt by a
rather wounded character in this case a
psychiatrist having a nervous breakdown
there are similar figures throughout the
rest of my fiction
to make something
positive out of the chaos that surrounds
them to create a kind of positive
mythology that can sustain one's
confidence in the world
so ballard himself is saying that my
novels
aren't quite so pessimistic as people
are making out and we might even say
with crash they're not as perverse as
people think right
he goes on as well and uh this is where
we get to something really really
interesting that i think is quite
revealing about what's going on with the
characters with the plots and in
ballard's own
mind and his experience
this is the being
fully human
interview
he responds to his interlocutor by
saying i ought to say first there seems
to be an underlying assumption by both
you
and the received wisdom of the day that
all disturbing or violent experience is
inherently
damaging
that is that experiences such as the
death of a spouse or child death of a
parent the stress of being uprooted from
one's home the hunger and privations of
war will all leave indelible fracture
lines that run through the wounded
psyche like a crack through a glass pane
and that even the lightest tap is
capable of inflicting irreparable damage
i very much doubt this
although i seem to be opposed to the
entire apparatus of 20th century
psychotherapy
the fact is that throughout most of
their evolution human beings have been
exposed to constant threats and ordeals
both physical and mental of every kind
and the majority of people recuperate
and make a full recovery if the death of
a spouse child parent if hunger disease
and privation were unusual
and deeply damaging human beings would
never have survived in fact they have
enormous powers of recuperation and when
a devastating blow like a child's loss
of a mother and utterly irreparable
disaster according to psychologists such
as bolby can remove be removed from if
the wider family supports can be
recovered from if the wider family
supports and loves the child and
sometimes i suspect if it doesn't this
is not to say
that genuinely horrific experiences of a
sustained kind like nazi death camps and
so on do not inflict lasting damage of
course they do
just as some people will never recover
from the wound of a
serious car crash
so he's saying here that the assumption
that many people have and i think it's
it's one that we do
in fact have in our own society
that
trauma
is inherently disabling or it's
ennobling or something like that he's
throwing those away
he's saying
people are different and different
people respond differently in these
situations but
many of them can
find ways to
recover
from the damage that's done to them from
the trauma from the injuries from the
humiliations from car crashes and the
damage done to bodies themselves through
that
here's a follow-up one from the inner
landscape interview your fiction seems
recently to be become preoccupied with
the image of the automobile
and the car crash
and ballard says
i'm not hung up on automobiles it's just
that it struck me as a
metaphor
and a key experience that no one had
ever looked at
the attitude to the motor car accident
was rather reminiscent to the victorian
attitude to sex and dreams the people
all assumed an attitude to the accident
which was altogether different from what
they really felt
take the deaths of people like jane jane
mansfield james dean and so on even
kennedy's death which was kind of a
modified automobile accident
the role of the car seemed to be a key
to the significance of whatever had
happened it is the most dramatic
experience that anyone will ever go
through in their whole lives apart from
their own deaths simply because one is
insulated in 20th century life from real
and direct experience even sexual
experiences muffled by a whole overlay
of conceptualization fashion chit chat
and everything else the car crash is
real
it is a violent experience that you are
not likely to get in any other area it
is a massive collision of the central
nervous system like a bad trip
a total explosion
of the senses
isn't that an interesting remark
and this leads into discussions about
metaphors
and obsession
so
in the paris review interview the
interviewer says let's start with
obsession you seem to have a
obsessive way of repeatingly repeatedly
playing out permutations of a certain
set of emblems and concerns things like
the winding down of time car crashes
birds and flying drain swimming pools
airports abandoned buildings ronald
reagan
ballard responds and he says i think
you're completely right
i would say that i quite consciously
rely on my obsessions and all my work
that i deliberately set up an
obsessional frame of mind in a
paradoxical way
this leaves one free of the subject of
the obsession it's like picking up an
ashtray and staring so hard at it that
one becomes obsessed by its contours
angles texture etc and forgets that it's
an ashtray a glass dish for stubbing out
cigarettes so car crashes can become
more than car crashes for example and
the interviewer says so you rely on the
magnetism of an obsession as a way of
proceeding and ballard says yes so the
unity of enterprise is forever there
a whole universe can be bounded in a
nutshell
of course
why one chooses certain topics as the
subject for one's obsessions is a
different matter why was i obsessed with
car crashes it's a peculiar idea
and the interviewer says yeah why were
you and ballard says
this is a beautiful line
presumably all obsessions are extreme
metaphors waiting to be born the whole
private mythology in which i believe
totally is a collaboration between one's
conscious mind and those obsessions that
one by one
present themselves as stepping stones so
you see obsessions
for ballard become
paths of access become
modes of developing understanding
and ways of deploying
extended metaphors
in an interview with
alan burns he
amplifies on this he says atrocity
exhibition and crash in which i equate
the crash with sexuality were both
extreme hypotheses extreme metaphors to
describe an extreme situation
then my mind turned in other directions
it just happened
another
interview search and destroy
asks him i was going to ask you about
crash were you showing films of car
crashes at an exhibition
ballard says no this was at the new arts
lab i just put three crashed cars on
display just there in their gallery i
did it as a sort of test
actually because i'd written my book the
atrocity exhibition in which i had a
character put out a display of crashed
cars and i was thinking at the time of
getting ready to write crash so he's
sort of
making life imitate art right
i put on the exhibition as a way to test
my
hunches
and that was interesting because i had
an opening party i sent out invitations
to art critics invited a lot of people
along i've been to a lot of parties but
i've never been to one where people got
so drunk so quickly
a crashed pontiac and a couple of
english cars
that had been in massive collisions
as we were setting up the show where
people walk in the gallery without
realizing what was going on they'd see
these crashed cars and you'd get a sort
of hysterical laugh at the actual
opening party
i've never seen people getting drunk
socially with so much aggression and
belligerence
i i nearly got attacked physically by a
reporter from the new society i had a
topless girl interviewing people and
hoppy the old tvx man connected with the
velux lab he had a closed circuit tv
going so people could see themselves
being interviewed around these crashed
cars by the topless girl it was too much
everyone got over excited the girl
nearly got raped in the back of the
crashed pontiac it confirmed all of my
hunches that show
during the month the cars were on
display they were continually attacked
they were rolled over splashed with
white paint by communicate men windows
that weren't broken were being broken
wing mirrors ripped off these wrecks
it's absolutely amazing the amount of
hostility
and then search and destroy said well
why is that and ballard says something
about putting these crashed vehicles on
display
focused pointed obviously a finger at
certain areas that most people kept
quietly concealed
their ambiguous feelings about cars and
car crashes obviously
were released
so
he's getting raw material for crash and
for these other works particularly high
rise
from doing this
living exhibition where people's
aggression comes out in full display
now turning to crash itself
which as we've remarked earlier is a
book that is chock full with sex
he's asked in the literary review
interview
most of your male characters don't have
any sex life most of them have left
their wives and now are on a lonely
quest but in crash there is a lot of sex
ballard says something
really revealing there's only sex there
the realm of the affections has been
obliterated
that's what the book is about
the transcendence of affection and the
emotions which is what i see as the main
achievement of technology i think we're
just on the threshold of this with
modern communication systems
microprocessors computerized memory
storage facilities visual display and
very easy access to it modern technology
is making possible the emergence of a
world where the whole realm of the
affections and the emotions will vanish
i think this will happen
a system of values which will be much
more strictly moral in a sense because
it won't be based on emotions is
beginning to emerge in crash i try to
show this happening
admittedly in crash it's a perverse new
logic which is generated but it's an
instance of a new kind of psychic order
which no longer requires the
intercession
of the emotions the point we'll have to
return to later on
in being fully human unless we think
that that ballard is just a consummate
pervert because of the book he wrote uh
crash he says the sexuality portrayed in
the
uh atrocity exhibition and crash has
very little to do with my own i own no
pornography soon become bored with films
on the adult channels in european hotels
and have been lucky enough to have a
long and emotionally close relationships
with remarkably few women
on the other hand i am interested in the
idea of pornography and how our sexual
imaginations are influenced and shaped
by the alienating effects of late
20th century life as i keep saying crash
is a love story
describing how a man and his wife
rediscover their love for each other a
fierce love which may be its own
warning i was on
atrocity is one sustained attempt to
make sense of the dislocations of the
world now that seems to contradict what
he said just earlier about crash strips
the emotions out of things
isn't it interesting to think that
love
between these two characters could be
what's going on
a little bit later
we have another interview
with alan burns
ballard says crash was a much more
exhausting and deranging book to write
such an extreme metaphor the effort of
maintaining the logic of two plus two
equals five or minus seven or
ninety-nine anything but four i sort of
hated myself as i wrote the book because
i felt i was dealing in things deadly
things like a sort of arms salesman much
of the book was morally highly
objectionable there's no doubt about
that
one of the publisher's readers was
either a psychiatrist or the wife of the
psychiatrist and she wrote the most
damning and vituperative vituperative
reader's report they'd ever received it
included the statement the author is
beyond psychiatric help that's a pretty
terrible thing to say about someone
particularly if you've got scientific
qualifications but i
was quite pleased by the report because
it represents in a sense
total artistic success the book had
worked if somebody could respond to it
like that to it but
doing that book was morally and
emotionally exhausting i felt far better
for it afterwards though like being
swallowed by a whale and then climbing
cutting your way out again burns says
was she implying it's a deranged or evil
book did she suggest it would harm
people and jg ballard says
i think it probably is an evil book
it may be a corrupting book but not too
corrupting if you read it you'll see
what i'm driving at
i'm trying to look at the sort of logic
that allows i think the latest figures
published by the world health
organization on automobile automobile
fatalities show that probably uh
250 000 people are killed and that's
probably an underestimate millions are
injured and seriously too what logic is
at work that allows this to happen
i think ballard continues that we're all
perhaps innately perverse capable of
enormous cruelty and paradoxically
our talent for the perverse the violent
and the obscene
may be a good thing
we may have to go through this phase to
reach something on the other side it's a
mistake to hold back and refuse to
accept one's nature
we're making a marriage you know the
equation sex times technology equals the
future
this uneasy and sinister marriage
between ourselves and technology is
going to change all our values
we're living in an abstracted world
where there aren't any values where
rather than fall back one has to immerse
himself as conrad said immerse oneself
in the most destructive element and swim
he talks as well about a book this is in
the high times interview which is his
bible
one of two bibles an amazing book which
i recommend you get crash injuries this
is a medical textbook on crash indus
injuries a book to have i had to write
to the states for that that is the
ultimate book all these comparisons of
facial damage and rollover comparing 52
buicks with 55 buicks bizarre
connections
actually one can read it in any way one
can read it without in any way being
ghoulish the way one can read the warren
report if you don't know what the warren
report is it's about the kennedy
assassination because one's dealing with
fundamental entities like one's own
musculature one's own sort of highly
conventionalized response to one's own
body one's tendency in time and space
things we take for granted and which are
really completely arbitrary that we're
all shaped the way we are is totally
arbitrary a fact we take for granted
something like the car crash with its
various injuries to say the human face
shouldn't be a subject of ghoulish
fascination nor the opposite
one ought to approach the material as
say an engineer approaches stress
deformations on aircraft tail play as a
fact of life which must be looked at
otherwise this plane may crash the human
body may crash so let's look at it anew
texts like that are a way of seeing the
human self anew which is very difficult
to do
but access to a book like that is not
easy for one thing you're never told
about the existence of the book
that book played a big part in my novel
crash
i don't mean that crash would have been
substantially different but it provided
the documentary underpinning otherwise
it would have been just fantasy which it
wasn't
those two books are really in their
different ways my two bibles
switching to concrete island
in the burns interview
burns asks him as so often in your work
concrete island is a physical almost
geographical representation of a state
of mind
and ballard says
absolutely it's about a man marooned on
a traffic island a man who's already
marooned psychologically before he gets
trapped on this island by accident the
island is a state of mind this traffic
island is not the balisha beacon zebra
crossing type of traffic island it's a
big triangle of waste ground between and
below three converging motorways
somewhere like west way surrounded by
high re high rise concrete blocks
the waste ground is strewn with
industrial refuse old car bodies all the
refuse of post-technological man and he
survives quite apart from his problems
he's within the intense technological
landscape
which is an extension of the things i'm
interested in atrocity exhibition and
notice the connection here we have
motorways crash is involved with that
crash is situated around an airport for
the most part um
concrete island is is also got you know
these concrete block buildings around it
like high rise high high-rise itself is
a sort of island in the middle of the
city so this is a
something that has some significant
implications for the other works
in the search and destroy interview
search and destroy said that another
thing very noticeable and high rise in
concrete island is that modern isolation
because of all that as in the case of
the guy on the concrete island you can
actually be on the road trying to hitch
a ride you might as well be light years
away and
ballard says you can't stop here and you
can't stop there even if you wanted to
if you're driving along say the west way
in your shepherd's bush at 60 miles an
hour and you saw somebody bleeding by
the roadside you try to stop you'd be in
a multi-car pileup you'd be dead you'd
be hit by about 15 to 20 cars and of
course you don't want to stop the whole
system is engineered around the
assumption that nobody is going to
express any impulsive charity or do
anything impulsive for that matter
you no more can express some original
impulse than somebody riding a roller
coaster who suddenly decided to get off
once the roller coaster begins you have
to ride it through to the end
many of these modern escapes are
beautifully landscaped actually the old
people who lived around are complaining
like mad they're not complaining about
the noise
but the destruction of the visual
amenities
we remember what the haren road was like
and look at it now
but the motorway is the most elegant
structure in that part of london the
houses are all decaying rex
finally um
in the literary review interview
we have a very interesting thing to end
on
the interviewer says you've been likened
to
conrad joseph conrad and greene graham
greene two writers who are never
mentioned are da'sod and george bataille
are they conscious interviews
influences
and ballard says i've got to make a
terrible confession i've never read a
word by either writer though i'm very
familiar with their names people have in
fact conventionally referred to my
connections with the sod i think that
particular strand of my fiction which
began with the atrocity exhibition and
culminated with crash grew spontaneously
and wasn't directly influenced by anyone
i'm aware of desaad as one of the
inspiring figures of modern surrealism
he interests me though i've never read a
word on him
of him because of his interest in
science and physiology perhaps i'm
putting my own gloss on decide i have no
idea whether his pornographic flights of
fancy resemble those in crash and then
the interviewer says well they do to a
certain extent he writes very clinically
and then
uh
ballard says right
as for bataille he crops up all over the
place but i've never read any novels by
him he's one of the members of that
invisible library along with various
other surrealist pioneers that i have
not read i have read most of rimbo's uh
poems in english i've read janae's
novels those two i'm happy to claim as
powerful influences on me notice that he
doesn't bring up conrad or green
at all in response to this but only
assad and bataille
and i think that's kind of kind of
interesting it's always tempting to read
into authors oh well they must have read
this and they must be responding to that
and then you find out that that's not
the case at all that creativity can
follow similar lines
um you know depending on where we are
coming from and what we choose to work
with so that gives you some real insight
i think into what's going on
in ballard's work as a whole and in
particular
these three novels that succeed each
other so quickly in just a matter of
years crash concrete island and high
rise
when it comes to speculative fiction
it's not that common of an occurrence
where we see
a philosopher of major significance and
status
singling out a sci-fi or horror or
fantasy or pick whatever you like author
as
uh you know forging a new path as
perhaps the superlative representative
of something that the philosopher is
particularly interested in
and with
jg ballard we have these two very
interesting essays
that uh jean baudrillard the famous
french philosopher the one who's always
talking about the hyper reel and about a
whole bunch of other
interesting related topics uh baldriard
focuses
on ballard in these two essays one is
actually specifically about ballard and
about crash and the other is a little
bit more general and also mentions
philip k dick at the very end
we see that
baudrillard is going to say
crash is the first great novel
of the universe of simulation the world
that we will be dealing with
from now on a
non-symbolic universe but one which by a
kind of reversal of its mass mediated
substance including neon concrete cars
mechanical eroticism
seems truly saturated with an intense
initiatory
power now how much of that is hyperbole
and stringing words and concepts
together how much of it is really
substantive well that's something we
have to delve into so i thought it would
be good to just go through these two
essays and also bring in one
other closely connected distinction that
baudrillard is going to make when it
comes to
signs and images from his essay
simulacra and simulations so why don't
we begin with that
baudrillard
is quite famous if you you know go to
wikipedia or anything like that for this
four part succession right he says that
these would be
the successive phases of the image first
it is the reflection of a basic reality
so there's reality there the image is a
reflection of it
second it masks and
perverts
a basic reality
third it masks the absence of a basic
reality and then fourth
it bears no relation to any reality
whatever it is its own
pure
simulacrum and what we've got here is a
progression where
images signs similac or whatever we want
to call them are
both you could say estranging themselves
liberating themselves from the dominance
of real or reality the
real as opposed to the imaginary
and eventually supplanting it turning
into what baudrillard calls the
realm
or the condition of the hyper reel and
he goes on
and he says
in the first place the image is a good
appearance the representation is of the
order of sacrament it allows us to
participate in the thing itself the the
reality in the second it is an evil
appearance of the order of
malefice
uh because it masks right it conceals
but also perverts the basic reality
in the third it plays at being an
appearance it is of the order of sorcery
and then in the fourth it is no longer
of the order of appearance at all
uh it is a simulation and he says the
transition from signs which to simulate
something to signs which to simulate
that there is nothing
marks the decisive
turning point the first implies the
theology of truth and secrecy the second
inaugurates an age of simulacra and
simulation in which there's no longer
any god to recognize his own nor any
last judgment to separate truth from
false the real from its artificial
resurrection since everything is already
dead and risen in advance and then he
goes on and says when the real is no
longer what it used to be nostalgia
assumes its true meaning there is a
proliferation of myths of origin and
signs of reality of second hand truth
objectivity and authenticity there's an
escalation of the true of the lived
experience a resurrection of the
figurative where the object and
substance have disappeared and there's a
panic stricken
production of the real and referential
above and parallel to the panic of
material
production
and he says this is how the simulation
appears in the phase that concerns us a
strategy of the real neo-real and
hyper-real right
now in the ballard essays
he says there are three orders
of similacra so it doesn't map on quite
exactly and these are tied in very
interestingly
with you could call it a history of
information right the first he says is
natural naturalistic simulacra based on
image imitation and counterfeiting
they are harmonious optimistic and aim
at the reconstitution or the ideal
institution of a nature in god's image
so we're still within the realm of the
real and the imaginary and the play back
and forth between the two of them
second productive productionist
simulacra based on energy and force
materialized by the machine and the
entire system of production their aim is
promethean worldwide application
continuous expansion
liberation of indeterminate energy
desire is part of the utopia's belonging
to this order of simulacra and then the
third
simulation simulacra based on
information the model
cybernetic play their aim is maximum
operationality hyper reality total
control and so bauderyart is saying we
move from one to the other and to the
other now it's not as if these can't
overlap with each other in the world
that we currently
live in he actually will will tell us at
one point that you know a computer for
example can be in any of these even
though we would tend to associate it
with the second or the third
and now he tells us something quite
interesting
so the first order
corresponds the imaginary of the utopia
to the second
sci-fi in the strict sense so the third
is there yet an imaginary domain which
corresponds to this order
the answer is going to be yes ballard in
particular
he says the probable answer is that the
good old sci-fi imagination is dead and
something else is beginning to emerge
not only in fiction but also in
theory
and so he tells us there's no real and
no imaginary except at a certain
distance what happens when this distance
begins to disappear
and be absorbed by the model alone so
what he's narrating here
is a collapse of the real and the
imaginary and the distinction between
them something that ballard himself is
playing with when he's talking about the
importance of interior space and that
you know we're not going to be doing
space opera anymore not as if you know
all of that goes away right
but the real advances in sci-fi are
going to be books
like these
like crash like concrete island like
high-rise where the sci-fi elements
are not quite so easy to
identify
and baudrillard is going to go on and
he says that
perhaps the sci-fi of this era the era
he takes us as being in
of cybernetics and hyper-reality will
only be able to attempt to artificially
resurrect the historical worlds of the
past trying to reconstruct in vitro and
down to its tiniest details the various
episodes of bygone days
all now empty of meaning of their and of
their original essence but hypnotic
with retrospective truth
and he goes on he says we can no longer
imagine other universes and the gift of
transcendence has been taken
from us as well classic sci-fi was one
of expanding universes it found its
calling in narratives of space
exploration coupled with more
terrestrial forms of exploration and
colonization indigenous to the 19th and
20th centuries and then he says
something really interesting there is no
cause effect relationship to be seen
here why
well because things are more complicated
than just plain old cause and effect he
says terrestrial space has been
virtually completely encoded mapped
inventoried saturated it's been shrunk
by globalization it's become a
collective marketplace not just for
products
but also for values signs and models
thereby leaving no room anymore for the
imaginary now
we'll come back to that that that's a
bold assertion
on baldriard's part isn't it
and he goes on and he says
it's not exactly because of all this
that the exploratory universe of sci-fi
has also stopped functioning
but these two phenomena are closely
linked after a period a period of
implosion after centuries of explosion
and expansion when a system reaches its
limits its own saturation point a
reversal begins to take place and
something happens also to the
imagination he says we have had large
reserves of the imaginary
but
that's changing
reality
as an internally coherent and limited
universe begins to hemorrhage when its
limits are stretched to
infinity
and he he goes on and he says from this
point on something must change
the projection the extrapolation the
sort of pantographic exuberance which
made up the charm of sci-fi are now no
longer possible again notice these
sweeping conclusions on baudrillard's
part
it is no longer possible to manufacture
the unreal from the real to create the
imaginary from the data of reality the
process will rather be the reverse to
put in place de-centered
situations models of simulation then to
strive to give them the colors of the
real the banal the lived to reinvent the
real as fiction
precisely because the real has vanished
from our lives let's pause there for a
moment and think about these three
novels and the fact that they don't have
typical sci-fi tropes or settings or
anything
like that
and yet they are definitely
within this realm that baudrillard is
talking about and ballard himself
considers them to be a kind of
sci-fi right so how are they
they are
ways in which and let's you know we
let's talk about crash we're going to
talk a lot about it
it's set in our world actually it's set
in a time
that's you know now quite a ways in the
past but one that we can still recognize
around
airports around houses in cars that are
colliding with each other and deforming
themselves and forming the people within
them and you know the sexuality that's
involved
in it you know sort of like putting car
parts together in a variety of different
ways
in a way that undermines
we could call it the traditional tropes
of sexuality and then we have
concrete island again car related
but now circumscribed by these highways
that have cut off space and yet people
live in there yet people
do things and have adventures or
conflicts and life and death
as one of the characters is going to
die in this and sex and
won't say love but certainly
attachment of a certain sort and then we
have high-rise
taking place
it does have a parking lot people do
drive a little bit but it's mostly
within the tower complex
right
and
society
or the projection of society into the
tower complex
breaks down along with the mechanics
of it whereas in crash we have the human
body and the automobile brought together
in interesting perhaps you know perverse
ways
here we have the human being in a social
matrix
being brought together within a building
that is breaking down not by
accidents but by many different types of
entropy and so are the
human beings within it
baudrillard goes on
and he says that where can we find
fictional works which incorporate
this condition of reversion and he says
well philip k dick of course
i'm not convinced by what poetry art is
saying about
dick
and then he says perhaps an even more
convincing example would be b would be
ballard and his fictional evolution from
his earliest
phantasmagorical short stories poetic
dreamlike alienating to crash
which
even more than high riser concrete
island so those do
figure into it constitutes without doubt
the contemporary model for this sci-fi
which is no longer sci-fi
crash
is our world
nothing is really invented with therein
everything is hyper functional traffic
and accidents technology and death sex
and the camera i everything is like a
huge simulated and synchronous machine
an acceleration of our own
models of all the models which surround
us
all mixed together and hyper
operationalized in the void and again we
could say about these as well so if
crash is
a model that has to do with sexuality in
a certain way and car crashes
this has to do with our isolation
concrete island
and
making a life for ourself once things
break down
and high-rise
similarly is you know it's it's it's a
fiction but it's set within
our uh
world right nothing is really invented
there's an acceleration of the model of
the breakdown of
utopia within a
high-rise apartment situation and he
says in crash
there's neither fiction nor reality
a kind of hyper reality
has abolished
both
hyper reality in the sense that
baudrillard is using this where we're
now within a universe of similacra signs
images where they don't actually refer
back to some reality that we could trace
things back to but they constitute their
own
realm
and he goes on
he tells us
and now this is in the second essay
ballard's crash
he says in crash technology is the
deadly deconstruction of the body no
longer a functional medium but an
extension of death dismemberment and
mutilation
not in the pejorative vision of a lost
unity of the subject the perspective of
psychoanalysis
but the explosive vision of a body given
over two symbolic wounds a body commixed
with technologies capacity for violation
and violence and in the brutal surgery
it continually performs in creating
incisions
excisions scar tissue gaping body holes
of which sexual wounds and central
pleasures are only a
case in point
a body with neither organs nor organ
pleasures entirely dominated by gash
marks excisions and technical scars
under the gleaming sign of a sexuality
that is without referentiality
and without limits now what does it mean
to have a sexuality without
referentiality
you could say well that's a pure
sexuality right but even the sexuality
isn't
referring to like a true pure sexuality
behind the scenes that we could like be
liberated towards
as a matter of fact as it's going to
turn out in
ba in uh um baudrillard's reading of
ballard's crash sexuality is just kind
of a
genre of things fitting into a much
larger genre of what it is that makes us
human and
he goes on and he says
the technological is never grasped
except by auto accident in other words
by the violence done to itself and the
violence done to the body
the codifying of the body as a workforce
in the order of production an earlier
way of understanding the body
is replaced by the dispersion of the
body as anagram so reversing and you
know re-scrambling letters in the order
of mutilation
gone are the erogenous zones that's very
important for sexuality right erogenous
zones are the places where we get turned
on that you can
touch and do things with now you can
still of course touch a lot
which happens like on every page and
crash
right and you know in in fight quite a
few things in the other two novels as
well
everything becomes a hole for reflex
discharges he says right
and he says there's no affectivity
behind this okay so that kind of
corresponds to what ballard himself has
said about you know in a
crash we're talking about sex and
sexuality without emotion but
is there really no affectivity per se
so
baudelaire is saying no psychology no
ambivalence or desire no libido or death
drive and i would say okay that that
kind of makes sense if what we're doing
is always like interpreting the
character like vaughn for example vaughn
driven by the freudian death drive okay
that's probably wrong right but vaughn
really does want to screw
and to
invade and be invaded and to be a voyeur
and to he has desires he's actually
driven by his desires so i don't think
that baudrillard is actually right in
that interpretation
he goes on and he says
death is a natural implication in this
limitless exploration of the possible
forms of violence done to the body but
this is never as in sadism or masochism
what the violence purposely and
perversely aims at never a distortion of
sense and sex there's no repressed
unconscious therein except a via second
reading which would necessarily
re-inject more twisted meaning in order
to conform to the psychoanalytic model
the nonsensicalness the brutality of
this mixture of body and technology is
totally imminent now that's kind of a
utopian point there as well maybe
baudrillard is smuggling in a little bit
of utopianism into his super
sophisticated reading here
one thing that he does say that i think
is really quite interesting though
in the next paragraph
another point in common
in crash the reader needs no longer to
contend with accidental signs that would
appear only on the margins of the system
the accident in capital a
portrayed here is no longer the
haphazard bricolage that it is still in
most highway accidents the bricolage of
the new leisure class's death drive
the accident is everywhere as
irreversible and fundamental trope the
of the anomaly of death it is no longer
on the margins
it is at the heart this is the part i
think is particularly apt
it is no longer the exception
to a triumphant rationality
it has become the rule
it has devoured the rule we are within a
new
order in what is being depicted in crash
but i would also say in high-rise and
concrete island as well and i would
actually say more successfully
in these other novels it seems like
there's much more attention paid to
crash than to these other two but i
think that the same thing is
going on there
a little bit later on he's going to
contrast
what's going on to the body
and the machine
in crash to what happens in
kafka's the penal colony a great short
story if you haven't read that
what poetry art has to tell us about the
machine in kafka's the penal colony is
this the body
via its wounds is still the locus of
textual inscription therefore on the one
hand the machine of kafka is still
puritanical repressive a signifying
machine as deluse would say
now what's going on there if you haven't
read the penal colony or in in the penal
colony there's a machine and as soon as
somebody
does something wrong
a prisoner that they're tied into this
machine which tattoos on their body
the judgment itself the things that they
did wrong and they're supposed to like
perceive it
through their body and it does it in a
very long and complicated way which
ultimately produces the horrifying death
but also
supposedly
an enlightenment and and the story
itself calls this into question you know
the explorer views this as inhumane and
the
captain's explanation is rather dubious
and then the captain himself
puts himself into the machine which is
in the process of breaking down so
now that you know that what is
bodriard saying about ballard the
technology of crash is glistening and
seductive or unpolished and innocent
why
seductive because it has been stripped
of meaning a simple mirror of torn
bodies
and the body of vaughan is likewise a
mirror of twisted chrome crumpled
fenders and semen tarnished sheet metal
bodies and technology fused seduced
inextricable
one from the
other
now a little bit later in this same
essay
going back to this theme of hyper
reality
this is what ballard has to say
what distinguishes crash from most other
sci-fi works is that the latter cell
still seem to revolve around the same
old duel of function
and dysfunction they project into the
future along the same lines of force and
the same finalities as that of the
normal universe right so they're doing
an imaginative projection
in crash there is neither fiction nor
reality
a kind of hyper reality moderate's key
concept has abolished both
he goes on further and he says
even critical regression is no longer
possible
this violent sexualized world totally
lacking in desire full of violent and
violated bodies but curiously neutered
this chromatic and intensely metallic
world empty of the sensorial a world of
hyper technology with finality is it
good or bad
and the answer is
who can say
right he goes on and he says we can't
say
it is simply fascinating
without this fascination implying any
kind of value judgment whatsoever and
this is the miracle of crash the moral
gaze the critical judgmentalism that is
still part of the old world's
functionality cannot touch it
crash is hypercritical in the sense of
being beyond the critical and even
beyond its own author we'll come back to
that in just a moment
is baudrillard right about this or is he
over playing his hand when we read
crash are we
merely
fascinated captivated by it i mean it
actually after a while becomes kind of
boring
frankly
you know it's attempts to shock with
you know all sorts of descriptions of
sex on almost every page or at least
violence of some sort wounds and stuff
like that
after a while
wears you out it doesn't fascinate
everybody i mean there are some people
who have the old-fashioned puritanical
oh this is terrible stuff right but even
if you're like yeah okay i'm gonna see
where this goes
i myself find crash
less interesting than these other two
and frankly i find uh high rise to be
the most interesting
of these
you know uh
concrete island is is is a distant
second i would say to
high rise in that respect so once again
maybe baudrillard is overplaying his
hand
it is possible to talk about goodness
and badness or moral judgment but
perhaps it has to be done
differently now here's where he talks
about ballard himself he says it goes
it's hypercritical it goes beyond its
own author who in the introduction
speaks of this novel as cautionary a
warning against that brutal erotic and
overlit realm that beckons more and more
persuasively to us from the margins of
the technological
landscape
i always find it a little bit curious
when critics
credit themselves with understanding the
works better than the author
him or herself
and i think this may be one of these but
it's an interesting
dialectic at least to bring the two
into them coming back to this this
earlier part of the essay
one of the things that he tells us about
the sexuality of crash
every gash mark every bruise every scar
left on the body is an artificial
invagination like those of the ritual
scarrings of aborigines which serve as a
vehement answer to the absence of body
right so there is
an invagination a
to some degree not feminization but
you know putting a entry point into the
body at each of these points and he says
only the wounded body can exist
symbolically for itself and for others
sexual desire is nothing but this
possibility of bodies to mix and
exchange their signifiers i don't think
we need to be romantics or you know
utopians about sex to say that's
kind of losing something there if this
is all that's going on in crash
he goes on now this is very interesting
those few natural orifices which were
accustomed to associate with sex and
sexual activities are nothing in
comparison to all these potential wounds
all these artificial
orifices but why artificial to all these
openings through which the body turns
itself inside out and like certain
topologies no longer possesses an inside
or an outside sex as conceived here is
only an inferior
and specialized definition comprising
all the symbolic
and sacrifice sacrificial practices a
body can open itself up to not via
nature but via artifice simulation an
accident sex
is no more than the rarification of a
drive called desire in the pre-prepared
zones it is largely surpassed by the
wide range of symbolic wounds which in
us in a sense are the anagramatized of
sex over the entire body but then of
course it is no longer sex it is
something else this is a very
fascinating way to look at things and
again i think you could say that as well
about these that um you know what
happens to the character
in concrete island you know
is also similarly a learning about
oneself and about others through being
placed in different relations which can
include sex but are not confined to sex
same thing in
high rise where we not only learn about
human bodies but we also learn about
artificial human societies and their
breakdown and groups that get together
and then can't keep it together
as well as
the
what should we call it the tower
obviously
which itself is constantly in process of
breaking down and breaking up
so
that's kind of an astute observation i
think
a little bit later he's going to
point out something else that i think is
is quite good all the erotic vocabulary
is technical we there's no slaying
no intimacy in the sexual violence only
functional
language equivalency of chrome and
mucous membranes and it's the same with
the congruity of death and sex rather
than being described with pleasure
they're melded together into a kind of
highly
technical construct
and he points out something quite true
sexual pleasure perverse or not has
always been mediated by a technical
apparatus i mean we can think oh no
there's like actual like raw sex that we
can have yeah sure
sex is always as people point out 90 in
the brain but it's also mediated through
are you you know laying down in a bed
are you on a mat are you
bent over a rock what else are you doing
there's always technology involved in
sex so he says it's always been mediated
by a technical apparatus by a mechanical
process of real objects
but most often of fantasies what's up in
our heads
it always involves an intermediary
manipulation of scenes or gadgets here
sexual pleasure is only climax in other
words it operates on the same wavelength
as the violence of a technical apparatus
they are homogenized by technology and
encapsulated into one object
the
automobile
he also brings up one final thing that
we need to talk about another dimension
in crash that he says the dimension of
photography
and cinema and we might think about how
does this change in our own time when we
carry photographs on our phones and talk
to each other through
a vast set of cables and you know
signals called the internet
has this intensified it beyond the hyper
reel
of baudrillard is there a hyper hyper
reel or are we in a different sort of
situation now he says that the added
depth and raising of the visual medium
to the second order can by itself
suffice to fuse together technology sex
and death but the photo is not a medium
nor an order of
representation it is neither a
supplementary abstraction of the image
nor a compulsion for spectacle and the
position of vaughn the main character of
course in well a main character and
crash not the narrator ballard but the
person that everything is centering
around
vaughn he says
is never a voyeur or a pervert vaughn is
going around and taking all these
pictures right
so what is it he says the role of film
is part of the universal film of life
hyper real metallic and corporeal made
up of movement
and flux
so there's there's an awful lot that i
think we can
i won't say learn because that implies
that he's actually correct
but at least think about in bode
riyard's examination of ballard's crash
and his other works as well ballard
himself
was not convinced of bodryard's
reading uh this is all part of a a
sort of invited
symposium you could call it in a sci-fi
magazine and ballard himself you know
talks about a lot of this as being kind
of bosh
but i think that there is perhaps
something
to what bode reard is saying for helping
us understand
how ballard is still doing sci-fi but
sci-fi
of a very different sort
in these
three
novels that are succeeding each other
you know year after year after year
showing some common elements to
all of them
you